so now that i'm in quarantine i have
basically this one hobby which is going
for walks
i do everything on walks i listen to
podcasts i take
meetings there's just one thing that's
really hard to do on a walk and that's
reading a research paper
or so i thought until i learned about a
new project that my colleague kaz sado
who's based in japan is working on
he used machine learning to transform
pdfs into audiobooks
so today i'm going to show you how to do
the same thing how to use computer
vision
and text to speech to turn your own pdfs
into audio books
let's get started
so first i decided to chat with kaz to
see how he built his project
yeah i have converted the pdf books into
the text file
by using the vision api ocr feature
i have used the automl cables
to understand the layout of the document
and then i have used the text-to-speech
api for converting the pre-processed
text into the mp3 audio file so i wanted
to build my own version of kaz's project
that would convert research papers into
audiobook
so i'm going to copy most of kaz's
architecture first like kaz i'll create
a google cloud storage bucket where all
the pdfs i want to be converted will be
stored
next i'll use the vision api to extract
text from those pdfs which i'll later
convert into spoken words
i'll use cass's code which calls the
vision api from python
here's what the output looks like when
you pass a pdf through the api
as you can see it contains both the raw
text
but also the xy coordinates of the
characters
so kaz set up this project in a really
nice way he used a cloud function which
is a way of running a tiny bit of code
in the cloud when something happens
so in our case we'll set it up so that
uploading a pdf to cloud storage
triggers the cloud function that kicks
off our audiobook making pipeline
so i'm going to create a cloud function
too and copy cass's code into it
after we've converted the pdfs into text
we still need to decide which parts of
the pdf text we want to include in the
audiobook
for example we probably want the body
text and the title
but we probably don't care about things
like page numbers or references or image
captions
so this is where our custom machine
learning model comes in to do
what kaz calls remove the garbage text
the automl tables model can
detect whether a text could be a garbage
takes such as the page headers or page
numbers or the
body text or the other small labels you
can find in the diagrams
so to handle the problem of identifying
the garbage text kaz built a custom
machine learning model using a tool
called automl tables
to train that model he collected all
this information about the size of the
text on the page and its position
but in order to do that cass had to
manually label a lot of pdfs marking the
good text from the garbage text
it took like three hours for each book
and for the initial
uh five books i it took like uh
like two days yeah it was 16 hours
i could do that because i was in the i
was back in my parents home and i had
nothing to do
except for this one so in order to avoid
labeling data myself i'm going to use a
little cheat here
instead of building a custom model i'm
just going to look at all of the font
sizes and whatever font size is most
frequently used i'm just going to assume
that that's the body text and that that
should go into the audio book
if you want more details about my
approach and kaz's approach make sure
you check out the blog post link below
and now for the fun part generating
computer voices
i'll take it from here google cloud text
to speech supports over 220 voices
in 40 plus languages let's try another
one
i am your narrator i am your narrator
i am your narrator i am your narrator
i am your narrator perfect now that i've
chosen my favorite voice i can update
the codes that when i upload
a pdf and audiobook will automatically
be generated
let's take a look at what it sounds like
a promising path towards
formalization and general artificial
intelligence
christian segetti today ai systems are
able to learn solving tasks that used to
be thought of taking uniquely human
capabilities until recently
thanks for watching and let me know in
the comments what you want to see me
build
see you next time
you